con artistas de talla mundial como
andrea bocelli the killers carlos
santana patti smith entre muchos otros
la ciudad de nueva york organiza el
primer evento multitudinario tras 17
meses de restricciones a largas filas en
el central park para asistir al variado
programa musical que ofrece este sábado
el alcalde de nueva york bill de blasio
se espera la asistencia de casi 60.000
personas a raíz del aumento de los
contagios por la variante delta los
mayores de 12 años deben presentar su
carnet de vacunación contra el coi 19 y
los menores una prueba de kobe negativa
pero este aire festivo no se siente en
otros lugares en eeuu en jacksonville en
el estado de florida los hospitales
empiezan a saturarse de pacientes
jóvenes contagiados
es más probable que la variante del
'tata' que a los jóvenes estamos viendo
que las edades disminuyen con respecto a
lo que vemos en las variantes anteriores
está atacando a los más jóvenes se están
enfermando mucho y más rápido anders
eggert twitter la variante delta está
golpeando con tanta fuerza del estado
del sol que 1 de cada 5 pacientes
hospitalizados en todo el país se
encuentra en florida esta semana la casa
blanca anunció que tiene la intención de
comenzar a administrar la tercera dosis
de la vacuna a partir del 20 de
septiembre a aquellos que han recibido
la segunda inyección ocho meses antes
las autoridades tomaron la decisión ya
que han visto una reducción de la
efectividad de las vacunas con el paso
del tiempo y por el auge de la variante
delta eeuu administrado hasta ahora más
de 362 millones de dosis de la vacuna
contra el coronavirus y casi el 52% de
la población ya ha recibido el marco
completo de vacunación